[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
son cv est époustouflant des mondes il
en connaît mille îles et historien il a
été secrétaire d'état sous mitterrand
président de radio-france patron de la
bibliothèque nationale de france les
livres le pouvoir les médias tous ces
univers il en a été acteur et de premier
plan les brillantes carrières c'est
d'ailleurs un peu de famille on entre
dans l'histoire de père en fils en tout
cas dans l'histoire politique comme si
c'était écrit comme si c'était une
seconde nature est-ce que celle l'est
vraiment l'héritage est il parfois un
peu lourd on va lui poser la question
bienvenue dans un monde un regard
bienvenue jean noël jeanneney merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans ce
lieu magnifique se donne tournons un
lieu méconnu du sénat on est ici un peu
entre le passé le présent et ça tombe
bien vous avez commencé à écrire vos
mémoires la première partie s'intitule
le rocher de suspense chez seuil la
politique c'est dans votre adn je pense
qu'on peut dire ça comme cette façon
effectivement je pense pas qu'on aurait
parlé d' adn au début du 20e siècle mais
il faut être moderne ce qui est vrai ce
qui est vrai c'est que il ya une double
ascendance pour moi une ascendance du
côté maternel qui va plutôt chercher
dans la civilisation protestante
civilisation de deux souvent du refus de
civilisation de notre réflexion et sur
une civilisation de la république ou si
tu as donné l'importance que les
républicains ont eu dans la fondation de
la troisième en particulier beaucoup de
pasteurs et du côté de mon grand père
c'est un cas qui a été parlementaire
pendant 40 ans en particulier président
du sénat ici y aurait il eu ma blessure
oui bien sûr cette méritocratie
républicaine traditionnelle et grands
parents avec une forme de de
déterminisme familial aussi peut-être
même un peu de pression ou pas aucune
pression un déterminisme probablement
c'est à dire que ddd l'enfance j'ai eu
la chance d'être à l'écouté de débat de
réflexion
des vocations antérieures aussi puisque
mon grand père avait été ministre de
clemenceau et de de gaulle et que j'ai
joué
près de son bureau en dessous des
photographies dédicacées des personnages
que je dis jamais de pression jamais un
peu lourd à porter avec des phrases du
type toi aussi mon fils tu ferais de la
politique plus tard non non non d'autant
plus que mon père n'avait pas fait de la
politique à l'origine contrairement à
son père à lui avait été universitaire
au fond c'est une bourgeoisie qui n'a
jamais eu une bourgeoisie d'argent ils
vous choisi qui se situe à la rencontre
entre l'université
la recherche
quand mon père était professeur
d'économie et d'autre part une tradition
politique effectivement hérité ça m'a
sûrement dirigé dans le sens d'une
curiosité particulière et mais aussi ça
m'a appris à quel point s'il arrivait
qu'on fasse de la politique il était
essentiel d'être indépendant c'est à
dire en gros de pouvoir toujours
démissionner c'est fondamental c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs j'ai considéré que
l'université entre autres davantage on
ferait un lieu idéal si j'espérais si
j'escomptais faire de temps en temps des
escapades alors vous l'avez déjà un
petit peu évoquée mais pour que nos
téléspectateurs comprennent bien
pourquoi nous parlons à ce point de
votre famille c'est qu'effectivement
votre père jean marcel jeanneney a été
député de l'isère puis ministre de de
gaulle de l'autre sens entre il a
d'abord été ministre et ensuite
brillamment députés elle vous faites
bien de rectifier de l'industrie des
affaires sociales ministre d'état et
garde des sceaux quant à jules janet
votre grand père il a été président du
conseil général de la haute saône député
président du sénat vous l'avez dit
ministre d'état sous de gaulle lui aussi
une lignée de républicains en revanche
vous avez été ministre de mitterrand est
ce qu on peut alors parler de rupture
idéologique ou pas du tout aucunement
aucunement toute la ligne et se situe du
côté de la gauche républicaine entre mon
grand-père a été lu en 1902 en haute
saône contre le nationaliste fâcha et
avait été encouragé comme radical
radical socialiste s'était pas un temps
ont été affiliés à des partis à
proprement parler mais c'est vraiment là
la famille d'esprit écoles quant à mon
père je l' ai toujours vu du côté de la
famille de seconde appelée gaulliste de
gauche et d'ailleurs quand pompidou est
arrivé il s'est éloigné il a d'ailleurs
voté mitterrand en 1974 il a dit non non
j'ai pas du tout l'impression d'une
rupture j'ai l'impression d'une
continuité y compris parce que à bien
des égards mitterrand a mis ses pas en
notamment politique étrangère dans ceux
du général de gaulle qui rendent tout
naturellement qu est-ce qui était si
fort dans la police sic pour que toute
votre famille s'y engage comme ça c'est
justement le sens de l'engagement l'envi
de servir l'état qu'est ce qui vous ont
dit toujours que c'est pour servir
l'état c'est important mais il ya aussi
des satisfactions narcissique et aussi
le plaisir de lui de peser sur les
choses les hommes politiques qui dirait
le contraire vous mentir et changer les
choses et être quelque part avec le
sentiment que l'on va pouvoir à un
moment donné bouger quelque chose dans
le sens qui vous paraît bien et au fond
pour moi il n'y a pas eu de différence
majeure entre le fait d'avoir été
brièvement secrétaires d'état en effet
du gouvernement d'edith cresson puis de
pierre bérégovoy la fin à la fin du
septennat du second septennat la partie
de gauche en tout cas c'est pas très
différent des missions vous avez évoqué
c'est à dire radio france service public
et puis vous avez omis quelque chose à
quoi je tiens je ne serai pas reproche
émission n'est pas fini la mission s'est
vraiment donné le loisir de vous le dire
c'est la mission du bicentenaire de la
révolution française on va y venir très
bien alors je veux dire qu' il ya des
moments où on a le sentiment très
directement quand on est dans l'action
d'être dans la tradition du politique et
en même temps de pouvoir tirer bénéfice
du fait qu'on connaît un peu l'histoire
ce qui est intéressant dans cette
histoire familiale c'est que donc vous
l'avez dit votre grand-père a présidé le
sénat et que c'est votre père qui a
porté la réforme du sénat voulu par le
général de gaulle en 69 je voudrais vous
montrer ce que les archives nationales
nous ont transmis puisque les archives
nationales sont nos partenaires pour
cette émission je vais les regarder
c'est un document signé de la main de
votre père jean marcel jeanneney il est
alors ministre d'état de de gaulle et
adresse au général le projet de loi sur
la réforme du sénat et la
régionalisation c'est le référendum qui
précipitera la chute de de gaulle
puisqu'après le nom il va démissionner
vous en avez parlé avec votre père de ce
moment politique bien sûr j'ai sur mon
père et moi en grande intimité
intellectuelles affectives et j'irai
intellectuelle et par conséquent j'en ai
d'ailleurs nourri le premier tome de ses
mémoires que vous évoquez tout à l'heure
nous nous sommes beaucoup parlé m'a
beaucoup expliqué et du point peu en
retrait où j'étais j'ai toujours est
extrêmement attentif à ce qu'il pouvait
m'apprendre s'est livré en mai 68 où il
était au coeur de la tourmente bien sûr
et ça a été vraiment de 69 même si
j'avais déjà évidemment ma propre
histoire et mon propre
propriété anodin comme une démarche on
sait que c'est un projet de loi qui
étaient censés affaiblir l'institution
que son propre père avait présidé est-ce
que ça a expliqué à apa je vois que vous
avez affûté déjà votre question c'est en
effet une question qu'on lui a posé bien
sûr il y compris dans dans l'hémicycle
ici mon grand père avait été très
attaché au sénat bien sûr puisqu'il
avait présidé pendant dix ans mais il
avait néanmoins en 45 devenu ministre
d'état de 2 go on peut le rappeler
suggérer un certain nombre de
modifications et en particulier qu' il
n'y ait plus navette éternel entre sénat
et chambre des députés est devenu
l'assemblée nationale c'est à dire que x
néanmoins prépondérance de l'un par
rapport aux autres et puis l'idée
centrale était celle de de gaulle c'est
à dire qu'il voulait fondre le conseil
économique et social avec le sénat pour
que le sénat soit la fois représentatif
en différence de la chambre de
l'assemblée des régions et d'autre part
représentatif des des citoyens et des
citoyennes dans leur situation organique
à l'on peut en débattre à l'infini à ce
qu'on peut dire en tout cas c'est que la
décentralisation est en couple et à
l'époque avec la réforme du sénat
si comme mon père l'avait souhaité à
certains moments mais il était très près
à suivre la volonté du général on avait
séparé les deux si on avait fait que la
décentralisation
je pense qu'elle aurait été acceptée par
le peuple et qu'on aurait gagné beaucoup
de temps par rapport à la loi de fer qui
est intervenu sous mitterrand 15000 da
quant au sénat chacun pourra juger
rétrospectivement on peut voir
effectivement encore dans les archives
les débats extrêmement vif qui a pu
avoir entre le président monnerville et
mon père explique encore élite est ils
étaient dans une continuité et
monnerville lui disant vous êtes un
traître à votre alors je vous permettrez
compte tenu du temps que nous avons que
je laisse la question ouverte gaga sont
interdites qui a été président du sénat
pendant plus de 20 ans votre parcours
avouent-ils et il est parfait sur le
plan académique je me suis penché
effectivement sur votre parcours les
grands lycées parisiens montaigne
louis-le-grand normale sup sciences po
agrégation doctorat jusqu'ici j'ai tout
bon toubon l'échec au cif oui mais
justement vous ne connaissez pas l'échec
vous n'avez pas connu l'échec
peut être ai je pris mais j'ai pas pris
assez de risques pour connaître l'échec
je ne sais pas
il ya eu des échecs lorsque alors ce que
ça arrête une mission c'est en plus sur
des chèques mais enfin je reconnais à
celle émise et non non effectivement je
dois dire que j'ai pas eu d'échec j'ai
pas dû essayer de viser au dessus de ce
que je pouvais atteindre c'est
intéressant on m'avait dit je n'ai pas
pris de risques ce que c'est un regret
ce qu'il y a des regrets dans ce
parcours est ce qu'il y a justement
peut-être avec ce déterminisme familiale
ces grandes études des choses que vous
peut-être avec un peu plus de fantaisie
vous auriez aimé faire et pas ce
parcours académique parfait
c'est une c'est une bonne question je
j'ai un peu de peine à a regretté ce que
je n'ai pas fait parce qu'en réalité
j'ai d'abord été très sensibles au fait
qu'il ya une part de hasard il faut
savoir à peu près où on veut aller et
puis si vous prenez différentes étapes
que vous avez bien voulu rappeler chaque
fois il ya une part de hasard j'ai été
président de la mission du bicentenaire
le troisième c'est à dire qu'il avait
fallu que malheureux michel baroin meurt
dans un accident qu'edgar fort moeurs
maladie pour que je lui succède sinon se
répète et je pourrais multiplier les cas
les cas de ce genre de dos donc il ya
une part de hasard est un des éléments
de réponse est ce que vous dites est et
en même temps je crois qu'il faut à
chaque moment est prêt à saisir ce que
soit la fortune qui n'a qu'un seul
cheveu demain commence et il vous
propose c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
faire vrai dire j'ai je n'ai pas de
regrets il m'est arrivé de me dire que
peut-être j'aurais pu m'engager en
politique
en fait tu vises investir davantage de
ma personnalité de mon effort en
politique me faire élire ici ou là etc
mais j'étais très ému
j'adorais faire de l'histoire je devrais
faire délivrer devrait enseigner j'ai
adoré j'ai adoré alternée pendant que
souvent certains de mes collègues du
gouvernement
donnait tout triste parce que leur
téléphone ne sonnait plus on à la cour
des comptes quelquefois ce n'est pas
très drôle et c'est bon je retourner à
l'université j'ai fait des livres et
j'ai j'ai adoré ça et puis l'histoire
vous savez c'est magnifique c'est la
meilleure des disciplines et toutes ces
grandes écoles que vous avez fait vous
le savez vous l'observez aujourd'hui
elles sont contestées on conteste une
forme d'élite un peu formaté d'élite
déconnecté est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous observez vous aussi vous
comprenez cette défiance vis-à-vis des
élites où vous ne la comprenais pas il
ya toujours une défiance à l'égard des
élites encore une fois un avantage
d'être historien toujours
l'antiparlementarisme avant 14 c'est
quelque chose qui est très très fort
maintenant les grandes écoles je
n'allais pas les feux dénigrerait pas en
tout cas pas l'école normale supérieure
parce qu'un grand avantage quand on est
né avec les coiffer quand on a des
avantages familiaux vous avez évoqué
suffisamment c'est que quand même on ne
trouve pas les on trouve pas les
diplômes universitaires dans une
pochette surprise je veux dire qu'on
passe des concours et c'est ce que j'ai
fait par conséquent sa d'une légitimité
qui est complémentaire est ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui des élites un peu
défaillante est ce que vous trouvez que
les débats d'idées ne sont pas au niveau
- au niveau qu'il ya quelques années
vous dont la famille connais si bien
cette histoire politique et ce monde
politique et ses élites je suis comme
tout le monde souvent frustré par le
niveau des débats par les discussions
pas par la manière dont les choses se
passent par un certain nombre de
préjugés trop simple qu'on applique sur
les réalités vais vous parler des
grandes écoles je trouve navrant quand
on supprime l'ena il fallait évidemment
je reproche vivement au président actuel
il fallait évidemment la faire évoluer
on aurait pu avoir des idées dans ce
sens pour ouvrir en particulier le
l'ensemble de ceux à qui on peut faire
appel pour qu'ils y arrivent c'est très
important c'est essentiel mais mais mais
mais de là à le supprimer et a toujours
eu des élites et a toujours eu des
méfiance à l'égard des 2 c est dit là
sous l'ancien régime etc c'est pas une
raison pour se dire oh il ya sept jours
été comme ça donc c'est pas grave rien
fait c'est grave et un des grands défis
de la démocratie est un système toujours
infiniment fragile si vous prenez
l'histoire du monde est là la planète
actuellement infiniment fragile c'est
peut-être la préoccupation centrale
qu'elle doit à voir comment organiser la
réflexion ça pose des problèmes du côté
des médias l'histoire des médias m'a
toujours passionné du point de vue de la
représentation et du point de vue du
rôle des intellectuels le responsabilité
le la lors de voir à mes yeux toujours à
propos de l'actualité d'aller rechercher
la profondeur de champ à la fois dans
l'ordre philosophique sociologique et
aussi évidemment dans l'ordre historique
sacema c'est mon affaire c'est à dire
prendre du recul et situer les choses en
sachant que la tendance de ceux des
élites à se laisser porter un peu de
forfanterie
c'est toujours dans et que la tendance
de ceux qui n'appartiennent pas à ces
élites à projeter sur elle
ce qui ne va pas dans leur vie en
exagérant leurs responsabilités au fond
des choses l'essentiel c'est savoir si
la démocratie est capable de faire appel
au plus large nombre de gens pour
accéder à ces édite la scène pas ne pas
avoir d élite à la fois en termes
géographiques et en termes également la
diversité à quoi il faut qu'une
république soit tellement adapté à la
période que l'on vit en ce moment vous
fait penser à une période de l'histoire
ou pas j'ai pas compris la période que
l'on vit en ce moment cette période de
débat politique assez houleux certains
parlent même de droitisation d'extrême
droite isation des débats les gilet
jaune que l'on a connue est ce que cette
période certains pourraient dire c'est
une période prérévolutionnaire est-ce
que la comparaison vous paraît justesse
que cette période actuelle vous fait
penser à une autre période de l'histoire
elle me fait penser à certains égards à
la période la firme dreyfus oui au début
dû au début du 20e siècle c'est une un
moment que j'ai beaucoup pensé nier et
qui surtout auparavant m'a beaucoup
informé parce que pour deux lignes et
que nous évoquions tout à l'heure ça a
été un moment absolument important
essentiel en vérité ça posait la
question de la laïcité déjà nous a posé
la question
de
du devoir d'état de la l'état dominant
l'idée de l'individu
dont la liberté essentielle est-ce qu'il
fallait sacrifier ou non dreyfus à allah
l'intérêt public est la défense et à
l'armée dans tout son brio en attente
éventuellement d'une guerre par exemple
je pense que cette période est
intéressante parce qu'on a vu aussi les
extrêmes de l'ignominie on a vu je ne
nommerai personne ici mais on sent bien
que infractions d'extrême droite de
l'opinion si vent mauvais se lève et je
reprend il à dessein une expression du
maréchal pétain puisque l'un d'entre eux
il est tellement attaché
le il ya un vent mauvais il ya danger
effectivement qui arrive toujours que on
voit ressurgir quoi on va ressurgir la
haine de l'autre là la jalousie une
envie qui sont toujours des passions
mauvaise individuelles et collectives on
voit aussi le danger d'une déformation
de l'histoire c'est ce que j'allais vous
diront la réécrit un peu l'histoire on
la revisite alors ce tabou l'historien
que vous êtes dois voir ça avec un
regard un peu sévère j'imagine de la
sphère dreyfus effectivement tout une
parti d'extrême droite a raconté à
recréer l'histoire notamment la place
des juifs qui ont été si importantes
dans le pays dans l'histoire du pays et
qui avaient été portés par la révolution
française tout ça a été déformé jeu
pourrait pousser la comparaison
effectivement un peu plus loin mais plus
largement largement l'histoire
est toujours instrumentalisée mais
réécrire l'histoire c'est aussi une
manière de dire que les historiens ont
peut être mal fait leur travail est ce
que vous le prenez parfois pour vous en
tant qu'historien ce que vous vous dites
qu'il y a eu des périodes de l'histoire
justement les historiens ont travaillé
avec aussi une idéologie derrière et que
peut-être ils ont eux mêmes mal analysé
les choses de choses dans certains cas
ils ont bien fait leur travail par
exemple le négationnisme famille
consiste à 10 l existence d des camps
est d'aider et de la shoah ça a été
largement contre les épouvantables
remugles de ce qui faisait surgir la
mise en cause c'était un beau gagner ça
a été moins gagner je veux dire par là
loi gayssot de par le travail d'un
certain nombre de grands historiens
comme il ça va pas regardons les choses
s'étaient alors ça c'est très important
il ya de l'autre travail consiste à
réagir lorsque quelqu'un vient apporter
des mensonges évidents
et nous pensent évidemment probablement
dans notre conjoncture ou même cas que
moi
qui consistait à dire c'est pas vrai je
vous rappelle que se porter au premier
rang aimé mais pour ça il faut être il
faut être aidé par votre corporation
madame c'est à dire que la collaboration
s'organise entre les historiens les
journalistes
je veux dire qu'ils sont assez proches
les uns des autres mais ils ne font pas
exactement la même situation et qu'il
faut que les journalistes à bord soit
très informés de l'histoire sas avait
une grande distinction il m'est arrivé
de dialoguer avec des journalistes et
une grande distinction de voulait voir
travailler ceux qui sont vraiment les
grandes carrières ceux qui sont qui ont
enraciné l'eure l'eure leurs compétences
et leur lucidité dans la connaissance de
l'histoire voyez les programmes des
écoles de journalistes is d'importants
petit appel en passant donc si les
historiens ne doivent pas s'installer
dans une position
qu'il me ferait imbus d'eux mêmes et qui
dirait voilà j'ai forcément la vérité
les questions qu'on pose au passé change
et donc d'une certaine façon il arrive
que des réponses jean enfin tout cas
l'aimé mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
faut être sceptique je veux dire que la
vérité prend des formes différentes mais
la véracité ça existe et quand il des
choses fausses quand on dit que monsieur
que l'ex maréchal pétain a protégé les
juifs français
c'est un mensonge absolu et par
conséquent était tout simplement ça
c'est factuel il faut le dire analyse de
l'histoire de l'extrême droite sous la
troisième république son poids etc c'est
plus compliqué mais on peut éclairer les
choses vous avez parlé des journalistes
et des médias puisque je parlais du
niveau des hommes et des femmes
politiques du niveau des historiens des
historiennes est ce que le niveau des
médias n'est pas bon on n'est pas à la
hauteur est ce que les médias hystérise
le débat est-ce qu'ils alimentent
quelque chose de malsain selon moi c'est
une blague dire ça c'est une blague
c'est pas vrai d'une fariboles je veux
dire je connais l'histoire des médias si
vous prenez l'histoire des médias sous
la monarchie de juillet vous relirez
peut-être balzac qui disait le
journaliste épouvantable si on n'avait
pas inventé ça il faudrait surtout pas
l'inventer est déjà sous voltaire et
rousseau il déteste elle alors vous êtes
sous le feu d'une critique constante et
c'est assez normal que vous soyez moins
populaire que les pompiers c'est normal
de dans l'est simplement ça ne veut pas
dire que
il file d'un stage et par vous donner
des leçons diocèse j'aime j'adore le
métier de journaliste mais je peux vous
renseigner le l'histoire des médias on
peut être critique mais surtout je
déteste les critiques générales g2 les
médecins les les sénateurs
chacun d'entre vous a sa responsabilité
il m'arrive de m'exaspérer devant telle
ou telle méconnaissance devant telle ou
telle sottise marivaux montrait d'avoir
la considération à tiens c'est lucide et
puis c'est un choix courageux parce
qu'on discute ce qui est faux et puis
s'est informé parce qu'on a qu'on
connaît l'histoire et la longue durée
qu'on dit attendez c'est pas vrai ce qui
vaut à la fois pour pour refuser des
mensonges historiques est ce qui est
vrai aussi pour
pour organiser différemment l' équilibre
des choses importantes dans l'actualité
alors franchement dans
l'entre-deux-guerres
le journalisme c'était c'était quelque
chose d'extraordinairement critique est
j'ajoute un point jusqu'en 1945 vous
avez 2 40 40 45 vous avez des plus
magnifiques dans le nom le journalisme
écrit même équipe une vénalité de la
presse à partir des rubriques financière
en particulier qui était ravageuse et
qui a contribué comme l'a dit léon blum
en partie la déliquescence de la
troisième république donc si vous
permettez aux mre inviterez pourra
parler plus longuement c'est un domaine
il faut être à la fois déterminé comme
les autres et très nuancée
on va continuer cet échange mais avec
des photos c'est notre séquence photo
dans cette émission les téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent en ont l'habitude des
photos qui sont censés vous parlez en
tout cas je l'espère j'en ai 3 vous
proposer la première c'est celle ci
alors peut-être vous voulez regarder
d'un peu plus près parce qu'elle fait si
je la connais bien elle est ancienne
vous la connaissez parfaitement
certainement lui le téléspectateur je la
décris un petit peu donc c'est de gaulle
avec votre père et vous à colombey les
deux églises sur le porche de sa maison
à lui photos prises dans un cadre privé
en décembre 1969 vous avez alors quoi 27
ans et vient des gaules de gaulle a
alors quitté la vie politique c'est
après l'échec du référendum de 69 c'est
bien plein il est comment est ce moment
là il en veut aux français
vous avez un souvenir assez pressant
très précis je voulais raconter en
détail non mais moi
c'était très impressionnant d'arrivée la
dame arrivée à colombes et non jeu pour
pour dire les choses brièvement il
n'était pas ils n'étaient pas -et grille
n'était pas amer été sévère pour
pompidou le dîner complet
il sera ratiboiser enfin de l'anglais
mais c'était en passant ce n'est pas
essentiel était entièrement concentré
sur sur ses mémoires c'est de cela qu'il
nous a beaucoup parlé
avec des comparaisons historiques etc il
avait le sentiment que c'était le
dernier le dernier comme cadeau la
dernière pouvait apporter au peuple
français s'était lui expliquer sa vision
des choses ça nous a donné les mémoires
d'espoir qui sont malheureusement
interrompu par la mort et alors c'était
très intéressant d'en parler puis pour
moi j'avais le sentiment quand même de
rencontrer l'histoire et ce personnage
et c'est pourquoi je jeu lennar et en
détail il avait il avait en fait inviter
quatre anciens de ses anciens ministres
du type ans il appréciait qui n'avaient
pas accepté d'entrer ou qu'ils n'aient
pas eu l'occasion d'entrer dans le
gouvernement pompidou rupture et donc il
avait dit à mes parents si un de vos
enfants veut conduire la voiture
ce sera très volontiers le droit
d'aînesse fonctionner encore ils
repèrent m'a dit si tu veux conduire où
j'ai dit oui papa avec grand plaisir est
là qui souhaiteraient difficile mais
est-ce que simplement en quelques
secondes vous sauriez dire ce que
d'aucuns penseraient de la france du
xxième siècle pas du tout non pas du
tout parce que parce que je pense que il
faut pas faire parler rétrospectivement
de gauche que je pense c'est qu'on peut
trouver dans ce neuf dans son action
dans sa rhétorique dans sa pédagogie
républicaine des sources constante dans
sa correspondance aussi gelé toujours à
portée de main mais mais faire parler de
gaulle à partir de 1969 c'est une
imposture de réviser le gaullisme sans
de gaulle je n'y crois pas il croyait
pourtant beaucoup faut parler de gaulle
aujourd'hui gens qui se réfèrent à des
changes comme monsieur castex j'ai à
dire je suis un gaulliste social on ne
peut que rigoler
pourquoi pas parce que parce que c'est
aux cassettes gaulliste aujourd'hui
collis social qu'est ce que ça veut dire
en plus je suis tout à fait hostile à
ceux qui tirent le goal in vers la
droite
auquel appartient famille d'accueil
monsieur k sexe très honorablement
appartient pas qu'on tire vers la droite
le gaullisme c'est pas la droite l'a dit
lui-même c'est pas la gauche donc soyons
subtil soyons complexe parce que la
réalité complexe pognon 6 ans et nuancé
collet qu'on perde tout cas en tout cas
arrachons de gaulle à l'idée de
maintenant madame le pen qui prétend
qu'elle est gaulliste alors que monsieur
aliot clic est important allait encore
régulièrement apporté chaque année une
gerbe sur la tombe de monsieur bastien
thiry qui avait voulu tuer je l' ai
raconté dans un livre qui est voulu tuer
de gaulle le 22 août 1962 au petit
clamart et c'est ça être gaulliste
j'ai une deuxième photo et elle va vous
emballez aussi vous en avait déjà parlé
je sais que c'est un moment important
jessye norman habillée du drapeau
français chantant la marseillaise à
l'occasion du bicentenaire de la
révolution française place de la
concorde à paris vous présidiez les
cérémonies de ce bicentenaire
c'est une afro américaine qui représente
la france ce jour là est ce que ça a
fait débat à l'époque oui une partie de
la droite a ironisé
et cela nous a confirmé dans l'idée que
c'était une excellente idée symbolique
c'est symbolique à la révolution
française c'est d'abord l'idée de
l'universalité ensuite la france a pas
toujours été à la hauteur de son
ambition mais en face c'est ça qui était
proclamer à la face du monde et c'est la
première fois qu'on a un beau lille
l'épouvantable l'esclavagé et par
conséquent faire venir une noire
américaine de surcroît magnifique
chanteuse quel jeune et l'émotion encore
présentes tant d'années après en
renvoyant cette image et puis j'ajoute
que c'était aussi une occasion de
marquer que les états unis d'amérique
avait joué un rôle important dans la
diffusion des idées des lumières avec la
première avec la révolution américaine
tout ça allait dans le même sens et je
dirais que les ironies ou l'ena zard
qu'on nous a portés depuis le depuis la
droite et l'extrême droite en fait ça ne
l'a profondément réjouit et et vous
pensez à votre for intérieur qu on
pourrait refaire la même chose
aujourd'hui même chose c'est à dire
c'est à dire une commémoration très
importante pour la france avec une
afro-américaine jeu comme moi se faire
je l'espère à condition évidemment qu'on
reste universel et qu'on ne tombe pas
dans l'idée épouvantable consisterait à
dire que pour parler des noirs il faut
être noir que pour parler des des femmes
il faut être femme tout ça je vais pas
m'engager dans ce débat évidemment
j'appartiens à la gauche universaliste
qui doit se défendre passionnément
contre toutes les tensions de ce qu'on
appelle l'appropriation culturelle ou où
la culture plein de sales coach on dit
en anglais une dernière photo une photo
de la bibliothèque nationale de france
que vous avez dirigé vous voulez la voir
de près celle ci c'était l'inauguration
avec françois mitterrand en mars 95 vous
ne présidez pas encore à ce moment là
qu'est ce que vous a apporté cette
expérience de la bibliothèque nationale
de france vous imaginez pour un
historien qui a le goût de la chose
publique et le goût de d'être le patron
j'ai jamais dépendu de personnes c'était
merveilleux j'étais seul avec mes livres
j'ai eu la responsabilité diriger des
établissements et notamment celui ci que
j'ai beaucoup aimé pour être franc le
tempérament des journalistes de france
inter et ceux des conservateurs la
bibliothèque nationale de france est
assez différent donc il fallait traiter
c'est que la bafin dirigé à organiser
l'énergie de ses collaborateurs de façon
différente mais c'était c'était
merveilleux parce que c'était à la fois
une maison toute neuve à laquelle il
s'agissait de rendre une fierté après un
certain nombre de coûts qu'elles avaient
reçues au moment de la décision de
transfert de richelieu et c'était donc
l'idée que je pouvais comme historiens
et des l'histoire et puis et puis il
s'est présenté une occasion qui pour moi
était essentielle et que j'ai saisi
c'est à dire de de lutter contre les
gaffes a déjà contre les google contre
eux parce que à l'époque c'était le
moment où google avait annoncé qu'il
allait faire une grande bibliothèque
universelle qui rassemblerait tous
l'héritage de l'humanité et à ce moment
là j'ai eu l'occasion avec une
bibliothèque qui m'a vraiment suivi
passionnément qui était très contente de
proposer que l'on résiste en disant vous
n'allez pas abandonner à une entreprise
de paix honorable j'imagine et m'est
étrangère est fondée sur la recherche du
profit l'héritage de l'idée de
moissonner comme on dit dans le métier
de rassembler de donner à connaître à sa
façon avec son inventaire l'héritage de
l'humanité donc nous avons proposé une
bibliothèque européenne
numérique européenne le sort en a été
inégal n'est pas tout à fait aboutie
selon ce qu'on voulait mais ça a
contribué à développer la numérisation
qu'on appelle gallica la bibliothèque
nationale de france dans tout le monde
d'aujourd'hui se serrent les chercheurs
et je crois largement les journalises
analyste également journaliste une
dernière question jean noël jeanneney
c'est notre rituel dans cette émission
je vais vous demander regarder autour de
nous les quatre statues qui représente
quatre vertus qui nous entourent dans ce
dom tournon du sénat vous avez derrière
vous la sagesse nous avons la prudence
nous avons la justice et nous avons
derrière moi l'éloquence dans laquelle
de ces vertus vous vous reconnaissez à
l'éloquence e1 éloquence évidemment
c'est tellement important c'est un sujet
mon grand père devant nous vous parliez
des prix national comme jeune avocat
avait avait fait son travail de la
conférence du stage sur l'éloquence
judiciaire dans les temps modernes voilà
évidemment alors là je dois dire que
j'ai vite absolument de dire c'était
mieux avant franchement con qu'il ya des
choses que tu es mieux d'autres moins
bien mais ce qui est vrai c'est que je
le dis en hésitant au sénat l'éloquence
parlementaire était quand même supérieur
à l'époque de la troisième république
mais ça s'explique parce que à droite
ont été formés par les jésuites à gauche
par le lycée pendant qu'on avait
apprécié avait beaucoup d'avocats
beaucoup de professeurs les choses ont
un peu évolué et puis c'est lié à
beaucoup d'autres motifs alors donc à
cause de ça j'ai envie de saluer
particulièrement l'éloquence en espérant
que ne faillit aucune des autres listes
puissent aspirer éventuellement les
citoyens et citoyennes et parfois même
merci infiniment gendrey de janet
d'avoir été notre invité dans cette
émission dans son monde un regard merci
de vous être livrée de vous avoir fait
partager votre monde c'est la fin de
cette émission se retrouve très vite sur
public sénat très bientôt merci de votre
accueil
[Musique]